mais ne faites pas ça chez vous tous les
jeudis maintenant on sera en action
vérité vous allez tous venez raconter
mais enfin certains vont appeler
certains et si vous tirez une boule
noire c'est une action si vous tirez une
boule jaune c'est une vérité mais une
boule noire une boule noire vous allez
devoir vous allez devoir mordiller
langoureusement
non pas ça je sens que s'embrasser sur
la bouche la personne de votre choix
autour de la table
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui fut la courbe est ici à aa
une vérité donnez moi mes trois plus
gros défaut égoïste impitoyable veut lui
[Rires]
c'est une action âgées une bonne action
pour vous vous allez devoir mordiller
langoureusement à la jeunesse à
[Rires]
mordiller langoureusement le nez de
gilles verdez fera
ces deux packs pas ça chez vous
[Musique]
belga le noir et de séquelles les haines
[Rires]
c'est quoi vous allez faire le tour des
plateaux du plateau en imitant le cheval
[Rires]
[Musique]
regardez
comment vas-tu
saint john hayes jonah hill
c'est une vérité est-ce que vous avez
déjà couché oui avec quelqu'un de
l'écrit
attendez attendez ou quelqu'un de
l'établissement pour lui oui oui en cinq
ans quand même cinq ans comme à 303 3
ans et une seule personne une seule
personne en chine
j'en connais déjà 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]